everything is just quantumly entangled
which means both realities that you just
described are true Everything has to
exist on some kind of Continuum which
means that even what we perceive to be
the past is part of the future right
they're both entangled which means that
the higher Dimensions might just be
higher frame rates of Consciousness
we're at a lower frame rate so which
means we can't perceive the truth at
those higher frame rates it's just like
somebody who's like super awakened and
super aware and knowledgeable could
really regurgitate this information very
quickly they could see it fast because
they're responding based on their own
brain's ability to just to be with it so
it's very fast for them I mean while
someone who's on a slower frame rate of
Consciousness we could say is just
observing the reality at only their
limited degree of perception
so they can't see all the waves they
can't see all the frequencies which is
also why very literally people who are
more plugged in who access those higher
States Of Consciousness they are more
attuned to the whole spectrum of
frequencies they are more of the empaths
they can feel more they could see more
which is why psychedelic substances you
know make us also more ensuing to the
point that we can see at those different
like through the veil we could see the
different colors we can see the
hallucinatory experiences even without
the psychedelics through our own mind's
eye through the pineal gland through
connecting to the scalar field and
picking up that information like an
antenna which means you're really just
raising your frequency to the point that
you are operating at that higher
dimensional level even here on third
dimensional plane so maybe that's what
it takes for us to transcend it's
understanding how can we unlock the door
through our own Consciousness in the 3D
in order to understand how to how did we
even end up in the 5D plus to begin with
what if we if this was the first step
what if the higher dimensions are really
our future what if that's what it took
for Consciousness to learn how to build
the latter in order to access its
infinite potentiality kind of like a
kindergartner going through you know an
adult in life having to go through the
stages of awareness and disintegration
and wars and fighting and polarities and
then you know eventually merging into
the infinite one again it's all
happening at the same time
simultaneously this beautiful Divine you
know game
that's coming back to the same truth of
Oneness so I think for ease of
understanding this and for everyone
watching it's easy to understand the
concept looking back so in retrospect we
can imagine different versions of
ourselves throughout our lives versions
were slightly different we're doing
different things we're feeling a little
bit different maybe when we had less
information about who we are we
understood a little bit less especially
if we're at this more awakened level now
there's a more there's a lesser awakened
version of ourselves that we can
remember that reality is still real so
we can imagine what happened when we
were at the fork in the road that made
us take certain choices and go down a
different route we can say arguably that
those versions of us still exist
and perhaps if we hadn't made the
choices to take us where we are today we
would still be that version of self so
we can play with this a little bit and
think it's like an experiment
what if they do what if those versions
of us are still live and well and
they're going down a different route
experiencing a different fate of their
own maybe we experience an ultimate fate
in this lifetime but there's different
routes in order to get there maybe
there's different timelines where we
have more or less bumps in the road more
or less challenges where we awaken
slower or faster experience different
frames of Consciousness along the way
meet different characters operate with
different frequencies and mindsets
ultimately to get somewhere so maybe
point a and point B are the same in
between what's occurring simultaneously
or different realities in which were
these different versions of ourselves
operating under different mental
conditions all to get to where we need
to be
so to jump the timeline we have to
understand that that future self that we
want to experience it's also occurring
right now
in order to embody that future self we
have to think about what is that future
self doing what is it feeling what is it
thinking what reality is it experiencing
what frequencies exist in that Realm
what are we doing now that does not
align with that Future Self
and we start to think about really what
is our self what is the sense of self
that we believe defines us what is
permeating our entire world right now if
we consider the entire reality around us
to be a projection of our own
subconscious mind we have to start to
understand what is in the subconscious
mind what is it made of what are we not
seeing that is projected all around us
and that puts us into the position of
having to really reverse engineer our
reality from the standpoint that it's
everything in our mind that is
comprising our entire world so if we
want to Quantum jump we have to identify
certain factors currently at play that
we maybe don't want to experience so
maybe you want to jump into a reality
where we have an improved relationship
or you're more abundant or you're
happier in some way or you're healthier
so that means you have to be forced to
think about what made you unhealthy or
what made you unhappy or what puts you
in the place right now where you want to
change those things now you're
simultaneously operating in three
different observed observed States
you're seeing the present moment you're
seeing where you once were that put you
in the present moment and you're
thinking about where you have to be one
day which means tuning yourself to a
whole different reality
and you're actually existing in these
three different standpoints of your own
Consciousness now your Consciousness is
really just one one vessel it's one Soul
frequency which exists outside of all of
these three third dimensional
experiences but in order to Quantum jump
you have to sort of get to that
transcendental state where you realize I
am not this that I currently am I'm not
my past but I can be whatever future I
want to experience when I really jump
onto that timeline and this is what
emerges from this you know Quantum
creativity standpoint
that you can really play with your mind
tweak your thoughts fantasize about a
totally different reality based on your
different thoughts and your ability to
side with a different version of
yourself which makes you dismiss certain
things in the past which puts you into
the present moment of deprivation and
resistance and that puts you on a
totally different timeline going forward
many people have experienced you know
totally
spontaneous manifestations of healing
miraculous healing different things in
their life where they realized oh my God
the past was never even attached to me
to begin with
they cure themselves of unknown maladies
they didn't know why they have
manifested them in the first place they
experienced massive shifts in their
relationships they have Miracles come in
in terms of money Finance their career
and all because they start to entertain
a totally new possibility
so with quantum physics the whole
premise is that reality is fluid it's a
very spooky Quantum realm because
observation is really what determines
the outcome
so if we think about it from that
standpoint if we don't know what's inner
subconscious and yet our subconscious is
projecting our reality then we need to
learn to observe the subconscious to
illuminate the subconscious mind and to
make the subconscious conscious they'll
allow us to understand what expectations
are creating our world
because we know from quantum physics the
when we change the expectation and the
observation the outcome also changes
feels like
we can't see ourselves I can see people
like I I get it I it I see their
patterns it seems obvious to me I I pick
up on the frequency and like the whole
puzzle feels very obvious it's like a
kid's puzzle to me
but it doesn't feel so obvious then
there's always I'm like I wish I could
see myself as easily as I see other
people
so
it feels to me like where this mini
Universe of source
trying to experience itself right on a
micro level to the macro of supposedly
Source fractioning off to experience
itself learn grow and just know itself
like that's our own little world too
like everything around us is informing
us of us is this an accurate assessment
I think that's beautifully put that's a
very enlightened aware realization about
how the entire universe is a reflection
of you of your experience of course
there's more to the universe than we can
see but what we're experiencing in our
own Matrix of our mind is a reflection
of ourselves this is why when we change
certain aspects of ourselves or we see
ourselves more fully everything seems to
transform and very quickly because we're
just becoming accepting and aware in our
observation
so the same thing goes for quantum
physics it all plays into the same
concept of what Consciousness is and why
does it even need to experience itself
you know in the whole scientific
Community this is a major question the
hard problem of Consciousness why does
it need to exist like what's the point
yeah Consciousness is this thing that
has a very transcendental nature it's
truly a cosmic Enigma right why does it
need to know itself it's this substance
that makes up all things that lives
within every animal every tree our own
observation within the water every
single thing is alive and it's operating
as one with this Cosmic mind
so the only feasible answer is that it
really needs to observe itself it needs
to learn through interaction with
everything else what is the point of
existence what is the beautiful Harmony
of coexistence what does it mean to love
what does it mean to go into the
experience of completely being as one
with everything else
and that beautiful experience of Oneness
is what we can experience when we detach
from the separateness of I am my own ego
and everything else is somehow a
separate construct it's really not if
you are Consciousness then we have to
come into this awareness that we are
just the same thing that everyone else
is made of why is it that relationships
pull us sometimes into our darkest
places
Intimate Relationships I think they're
the most
they're they're most filled with the
lessons in our realities basically every
relationship it's the most telling thing
about yourself what are you really
attracting it's the best way to look in
the mirror Through The Eyes of another
person and how you're experiencing them
and how they're experiencing you
well right every single thing in a
relationship is part of the expression
of your own Dynamics with and within
yourself
so your partner ends up being your
greatest teacher they're either loving
you into loving yourself even more or
they're teaching you how to love
yourself to a point of maybe losing that
attachment and learning to attract
someone even better what is the point of
going through the pain
I think the the point is to just come
into the
the solving all of the resistance to why
it happened to get to the point that you
are the awareness that shows the
experience and you can fully come into
alignment with the experience to
dissolve the pain that's what leads to
the dissolution of pain and suffering
suffering is really just the
accumulation of pain that you haven't
observed and haven't come into alignment
with that's often what I tell people
pain is inevitable but suffering is
optional are we going to choose to see
the pain and acknowledge the resistance
and heal the triggers and go into the
Shadow and see everyone else's
expressions of ourselves are we going to
still keep denying that essential
reality that we know deep down to be
true and so there is no point there's no
destination I'd say ironically kind of
the destination is the point where
you're not seeking the destination
anymore yeah it's where it's just
business it's just everything is and
you're just happy with it being the way
that it is if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen